um thank you guys for joining us
do you i'll ask the ladies first i get
to the men do you think
mothers
or fathers are better at raising sick
children by themselves
start here
six or six sorry so do you think that
mother yeah mothers or fathers are
better at raising children by themselves
i would say like
me personally because i'm i come from a
family of two parents
um everything seems a bit nuclear so
even if my family parents even if my
family have arguments and disagreements
it's good to learn from both
parents you know i would i feel
better being in a nuclear family than
being in a single parent family because
i feel like
um
i wouldn't get the best of both
parents who do you think is a better
parent mother or father statistically
statistically
mothers
okay
by you
[Music]
honestly it depends who's willing to
step up to the job
i feel like fathers have a lot to offer
um
as well as women
and i mean honestly apart from
breastfeeding what can't a man do that
women can
men might be more inclined to provide
but that doesn't mean that they don't
have the emotional capacity or emotional
intelligence to provide for a child like
that same way a mother could provide for
her child you know financially in all
the ways that men typically do
um but i gotta say statistically
probably
the mother
as a mother what do you think
um
growing up myself
my situation was
shared parenting so i went half three
four days with my dad and half of my mum
growing up until i got to about age 11.
um i would say
um
there was things that i learned when i
was with my dad
and how and then also things that with
my mom so i it's it's in that but at the
same time
um
i would say
statistically mothers
but
not saying that dads cannot raise
children on their own i i think that if
if they were raised by um a two-parent
household themselves they will know
they will know how to do both so but
yeah that's what i would say charlie
you're a single father right um
yeah um
i don't think we'll we'll know until you
get the balance changing i mean like you
said
you get 80
is that right where the single single
family tends to be the kids with the
mothers so
if you balance that out with the 20
of dads that have their kids and they're
better off financially
if you've got a 50 50 ratio which i
don't advocate for i don't like things
like that but if you did have that you
might get a better answer to the
question
um i'll give you this a statistics right
pew reports that the median adjusted
annual income for a single dad with two
children
is about forty thousand dollars in
america
compared to twenty six thousand dollars
for a single mom with two children
so would you say that financially
we say well it does say financially
children are better off with us as with
single father i think i think it
confirms the gender roles actually you
know mothers are there to nurture and to
raise into real children
and men are there to provide and protect
i think that statistic actually goes to
show that that is the natural order of
things because men are more productive
in in the sense of what you describe
those statistics there
um
but i'm biased i think i'm a great dad
so i i don't necessarily think that you
can have
um a binary women are better men or
worse i think it just depends on the
person it depends on how you are
guided um how you're raised what your
morals are you know it's all those
things i mean i think you need them for
different things like men and women are
needed for different things but the
reason that i think men tend to be
better single parents is because women
are chemically different every day so
over a certain age it's very confusing
for the kid
because one day she's you know
more irritable one day less irritable
where men are more consistent like as i
think most girls can attest the week
before a period where
we're not playing
hmm
you just said that women are more like
um
emotionally unstable you would say yeah
so do you think it's the best advice for
her to have the kid
when she's emotionally unstable for like
for her to have the decision
um
i mean she should be married before she
was a kid no we're talking about like
modern day do you think the like until
like you know how road versus way like
the new abortion stuff do you think
that a woman during the time when she's
pregnant pregnant when her emotions are
everywhere her hormones are everywhere
do you think she should be able to make
that decision of whether or not she has
the kid or not do you think she's in the
right frame of mind
no i don't believe in abortion
so i think if that's your bad lie in it
what would you say yeah one second what
were you saying uh yeah the better
better parent is um so i don't think
people understand how
important the role of a father is in
when it comes to raising a child yeah
between the ages of you know from birth
to eight um the child being raised my
mother is fine but then from that point
on especially when you have a son
the father plays such an important role
in that child's life even men don't even
understand how deep it is so
every
17 of people um um children born into
you know single parent households
that get towards women so it's a single
mother um
[Music]
their life is way way worse than you
know if it was in the
um double parent [ __ ] basically and
even things like
if in a fatherless home a child is
41 of children are
make um sorry
end up making less than the actual than
their father
which pretty much makes like a perpetual
state of
not being wealthy which affects children
a lot you know
fathers keep
sons out of jail and those of the polls
some people say but it's it's actually
so crazy how important it is yes when
the young fair enough you know keeping
them on but when they get past a certain
age again especially with sons you kind
of have to stop
leaving them with with their moms
because especially when you have a son
you can't you know you can't really
discipline him as much because he's
stronger than you you know so you need
you need that testosterone to match
so single mothers are four times more
likely
to live below the poverty line
without a fathering house
in america according to
census bureau report u.s census bureau
report they're four times more likely to
live below the poverty line so having a
father in the house is essential
for the financial stability of a child
and also the mental stability
of a child
well many women are on track to be
homeless now because women um because
we're more emotional we tend to make
more like quick buying decisions i mean
how many girls do you know that are
addicted to like shopping and
i i can think of like five off the top
of my head and that's why a lot of
advertising campaigns are directed as
women because we're again we're
chemically different and we're more
likely to be influenced by that stuff
and so we're more likely to make like
quick purchasing decisions
um
but
the and women own two-thirds of the
world's debt
so even though we make ten thousand
dollars or pounds roughly
than men more per year no less less even
though we make less money we spend more
and 70 70 to 80 of consumer buying
decisions are made by women so it makes
a lot of sense to me that a lot of women
that are in single their single mother
homes are below the poverty line